Qué medidas puede tomar el gobierno
francés ante el fuerte descontento
social y más allá de ello está dispuesto
a modificar sus planes o aumentar
subsidios
muy buenos días va a ser muy complicado
para el gobierno justamente porque ahora
la asamblea nacional tiene un poder que
jamás había tenido antes Entonces está
el plan de presupuesto que está
presentado justamente para el gobierno
con algunas propuestas justamente para
una menor una mejor repartición de los
beneficios y una tasa extra para las
empresas que tienen beneficios más
importantes en esta en este tiempo de
crisis pero es muy difícil porque todas
las oposiciones han decidido de oponerse
en bloque a todo este texto entonces la
verdad al día de hoy no se sabe muy bien
lo que podrá salir de este de este plan
de presupuesto que que va a dar la línea
para el próximo año y con todas estas
reformas necesarias Ahora hay diferentes
medidas que el gobierno no puede
implicar porque de hecho son decisiones
que vienen directamente de las empresas
que son las empresas privadas como es el
caso para el petróleo y las refinerías
Entonces ahí es un diálogo social que se
pone en marcha solamente entre los
sindicatos y la empresa misma ahí el
Gobierno no tiene su palabra quiere
decir pero hay medidas que ya fueron
tomadas como la ayuda en el precio del
petróleo con 30 centavos entonces de
ayuda por cada litro para para los
franceses que se va a extinguir hasta
mitad de noviembre Perdón hasta la el
fin del año eso es una de las medidas y
también ayudas para renovaciones
ecológicas de de las casas de la gente
para ahorrar justamente en el energía y
también está el caso del precio del gas
que está mantenido a una inflación de
15% donde puede alcanzar un 100% en todo
el resto de Europa
bueno y alrededor de un tercio de las
gasolineras del país siguen enfrentando
desabastecimiento por las huelgas en las
refinerías el ministro de economía dijo
hace algunos días que activarían un
mecanismo para que los trabajadores
tuvieran que levantar estos paros esto
es útil o es otra forma de aumentar el
descontento social
es como la arma nuclear para este tipo
es la última solución que se puede
encontrar había dicho que justamente
todo está entre las manos de la empresa
y de los sindicatos pero cuando no hay
más diálogo cuando el diálogo fracasa
que no es el caso de acá porque hubo un
diálogo hubo un acuerdo con la mayoría
de los sindicatos El problema es que un
sindicato minoritario quiere seguir
presionando la empresa Para obtener más
y entonces tiene el derecho
constitucional de seguir haciendo la
huella Pero entonces para el gobierno la
única manera que tiene para desbloquear
estas refinerías y permitir las
distribución de este combustible es una
ley de requisas que se llama así de 2009
que permite al poder al Estado de
requisar el personal indispensable
justamente para evitar problemas de
orden público y creo que con la esquema
que estamos hoy con el 30% de las
plantas de distribución de gasolina que
están bloqueadas que no tienen más
gasolina estamos justamente en este en
este escenario y si una persona rechaza
este dispositivo de ley excepcional de
requisa se arriesga seis meses de cárcel
Y 10.000 euros de multa